from calorie count to portion sizes we
wanted to find out all the differences
between Hard Rock Cafe in the US and the
UK this is food
War let's break down the burger that
started it all the original legendary
Burger let's weigh the US Burger 318 G
here's the original legendary Burger in
the UK let's weigh it our Burger weighed
280 G that's a pretty big difference
from 280 to 318 G this is a heavy heavy
burger and of course all their burgers
come with a side of season fries we're
going to weigh ours to see how much
we're getting so our side of fries came
to 178 G they feel so soggy right now in
my hands so that is 126 G of french
fries another iconic menu item is baby
back ribs we're going to weigh our UK
portion to find out how much we're
getting is that too
heavy
335 plus oh God 300 635
G heavy this is
82 G of ribs that sounds like too much
ribs for one sitd down dinner that's a
lot of ribs the cowboy ribeye is
supposedly 16 o of beef let's see if
that's actually true this is 12.8 oz of
meat meat does shrink so a little wiggle
room is to be expected but that's a
pretty decent Chunk we booed everyone's
booed
everyone's booing me so after being
booed by everyone I I'll be more upset
about losing out on some of this meat it
just looks like such a big portion that
I'm like it's fine but it is 4 o that
were missing that was advertised so I
understand I understand why everyone's
upset strangely the cowboy ribey is
advertised as being 14 o here in the UK
I'm not sure why we're getting short
changed but we're going to measure it to
keep them honest so our UK cowboy ribey
has actually only come to
10 and2 o I understand that steaks do
lose some of their Mass while cooking
but 3 and 1 half o that seems like a lot
let's get into some apps we got the
classic nachos no meat this is food Wars
so you know we got to weigh these nachos
602 G here are the UK nachos I'm going
to weigh them with the paper cuz our
scal has had enough tror already a UK
nachos is weigh 510 G I'm interested to
see which country has bigger wing
portions so let's count them out count
them out with me we have
one 2 three 4
10 11
and 12 7 8 I'm going to let them have
this one I'm going to let them have this
one because we've literally been
destroying them in these portion sizes
this entire time so you know what you
deserve the extra amount of wings Hard
Rock Cafe is also known for its famous
onion ring tower now on the menu they
don't specify how many onion rings you
get in a tower however in a promotional
photo I counted eight so we're going to
count ours out now and see if that's
true or if we get more or less than we
were promised I'm going to try my
hardest to beat Harry in the onion ring
Tower making somehow built this uh the
wrong way around so it's getting wider
near the top
six
seven I'm not doing that again
8 9
10 girls and stem so while my tower
design failed horribly we did get 11
onion rings in our onion ring Tower as a
side what about dessert let's compare
Hard Rock's apple cobbler in the US and
the UK it smells so good I'm resisting
every urge I have to bite into it right
now we've got
432 G of apple cobbler so the apple
cobbler in the UK came to 37 6
G here are all the menu items you'll
find at a hard rock in the UK that you
won't find in the US here's all the food
that you'll find at Hard Rock Cafe in
the US that you won't find in the UK
there are a couple of burgers you'll
find in the US but not in the UK the
turkey burger and the impossible Burger
I think impossible beef isn't available
in the UK yet there's an ingredient in
it called soy leg hemoglobin which is
approved in the US but not in the UK The
Impossible
Burger
that soy leg hemoglobin is doing what it
needs to do that's the ingredient that
makes this taste like actual beef um and
it's working it's working for me I can
tell texture-wise in the back of my head
this is not beef but it's like doing
enough where I don't really care it
tastes pretty good there's also a small
difference in the classic legendary
Burger in the two countries the UK uses
just regular cheddar cheese while the US
specifically uses tilok cheddar tilok is
a popular Creamery based in Oregon I'm
not going to bite into everything here
today because we are going to give some
of this away but if there's anything
that catches my eye particularly then
I'll give it a try we actually have
quite a few exclusives in the UK so I'll
start at this end and work my way down
first off we have cauliflower tacos I
think they are pretty much as the name
suggests it's a taco which is a I think
is a flour tortilla with some pieces of
seasoned cauliflower in there as well as
some SLO some sauce and some jalapenos
next up we've got barbecue chicken this
one really just does what it says on the
tin it's just half of a chicken which
has been grilled and covered in barbecue
sauce it's almost unnerving how
accurately they have hared this
chicken it's literally they've just gone
straight through the middle of it with
like a laser beam and sliced the thing
into the next exclusive menu item is
fish and chips you get this a lot you
might have a company which branding wise
seems like it's not from the UK but when
they launch in the UK they feel
compelled to have fish and chips on the
menu I will have to try this one I can't
let them off the hook if they've really
butchered fishing chips although I will
give them again some credit for the fact
that this has been sitting around for a
while and therefore has lost all of the
crisp which I think it once
had it's not too bad I do think have we
eaten this hot and fresh it would have
been a bit crispier you can definitely
see some of the kind of like flakes of
batter which would have crisped up next
up we have the moving mountains Burger
now we don't have the impossible Burger
on the UK menu because as of right now
impossible beef still cannot be sold in
the UK Moving Mountains is a company
which does very similar things it's
making plant-based meat Alternatives
including a beef burger which is
approved for sale in the UK and is on
offer here I mean visually I got to say
the moving mountains Burger does look
pretty good it's got like a nice Brown
exterior they got the kind of like
grainy like meat fibers almost in the
middle and it definitely like looks a
bit pink
even I'm quite impressed by that that's
really not bad obviously it doesn't have
the exact beef taste that we used to but
there's definitely like a meatiness to
it every Hard Rock Cafe location also
has a local Burger which is inspired by
ingredients found in that area so this
is the London Burger on here you will
find a beef patty with some layers of
roast beef a horseradish Mayo rocket
some tomato and some lettuce now the
London Burger is Loosely inspired by a
British Sunday roast specifically the
roast beef I do think I need to taste
this to uh see if it's giving an
accurate representation of British
Cuisine they've been fairly generous
with the roast beef slices I have to
say cheers
you definitely do get that like roast
beef flavor from these pieces of beef I
think it could maybe have done with even
more horseradish Mayo cuz the flavor of
that is really lovely it's pretty good
whether it's a accurate representation
of London and London
Cuisine I'm going to go with no but is
it a tasty burger kind of yes New York
City doesn't have a region specific
Burger but they do offer a French dip on
garlic bread Joe made me aware that the
French dip was not created in New York
but rather LA but I can kind of see what
they were going for because roast beef
sandwiches in general are popular here
that includes French dips and they might
have chosen the garlic bread because New
York City has so much Italian and
Italian-American culture ingrained in it
I feel like I'm kind of reaching right
now but I'm just trying to make sense of
it all this is the garlic bread that
they speak of
um I think we need to have some words
with Hard Rock Cafe what is the sauce
called bless
you got her got both of them I'm taking
a dip I'm taking a dip you can do it you
can do it this is the coldest aou and
the coldest fridge
dip this is just not it go somewhere
else go somewhere where else Hard Rock
Cafe has also partnered with the
greatest footballer of all time Leonel
Messi now I'm not sure if Messi's diet
allows him to regularly eat at Hard Rock
Cafe however he's partnered with him to
release two burgers you can find the
messy beef burger in both the US and the
UK but in the UK we have an exclusive
one the messy chicken burger let's just
take a look and see what we can find so
we have what looks to be maybe like a
potato roll we' got some bacon some
cheese a big grilled chicken breast
there are some sauce on here as
well
mayonnaise as well as tomato and lettuce
if I take a bite out of this do you
think I will gain the footballing
ability of lonel
Messi whether that is a sandwich fitting
for the goat I'm not sure speaking of
Messi I think now's a great time to quiz
Joe and see if he can pick him out in a
group of photos he is one of the most
famous men in the entire world so it
shouldn't be hard right Joe so one of
these persons is uh Lionel Messi and uh
I don't know which one he is uh well
this guy's from Ted lasso so I'm
assuming it's not him or someone would
have said at some point can you believe
that guy is also a famous soccer player
uh this looks like a person who works in
a cafe so I'm that you tough times for
football players apparently I mean this
just looks like I feel like I've seen
this guy somewhere feel like this guy
works at Insider who's this this is this
can't be him this looks like a stock
photo and then this looks like a guy
from like a background extra in The
Matrix so so I'm going to think that
it's this guy oh it's not this guy yeah
this this guy is this super famous
football soccer player so I think I was
right this is Shutterstock though that
kind of looks like the Stinger from Al
[Laughter]
City
hey what do you want from me none of
this means anything to
me a legendary Burger in the US contains
1,610 calories now I don't know if they
mean 1,610 calories with the fries or
without so just keep that in mind
according to the FDA that is 81% of my
daily recommended caloric intake here in
the UK the original legendary B contains
1,375 calories which according to FDA
guidelines is around 69% of my daily
recommended allowance a lot of food
items on the Hard Rock menu are actually
super high in calories including the
baby back ribs which clock in at
2,433 calories here in the UK the baby
back ribs contain around
1,796 calories which makes the US
version around 35% more calorific more
detailed nutritional info for Hard Rock
Cafe doesn't seem to be available online
but I did notice this little tiny salt
symbol that was next to a whole bunch of
dishes this indicates that the sodium
content of that item is higher than the
total daily recommended limit which is
2,300 mg there's something about a fudge
brownie with vanilla ice cream that
feels very American food chain in the US
this dessert contains
1,122 Cals I think it's worth it though
this thing looks really good in the UK
the fudge brownie with ice cream comes
to 2,9 calories what we have here is the
takeaway version which I personally do
not think contains 2,000 calories I
think what they're referring to is the
in restaurant version which is an
enormous chocolate fudge sunde with
loads of ice cream sauces and More in
front of me now I have a starter of 12
chicken wings with buffalo sauce I have
the main which is the legendary burger
and fries and I have dessert which is an
apple cobbler now I would say this is a
fairly standard dinner I think it would
be on the heavier side for a dinner but
if I was hungry I could definitely
polish off all three courses no problem
however if I ate all of this I would be
consuming 4,
819 calories I think those daily caloric
intake values might be outdated and Vary
depending on the person I'm not a
nutritionist I'm just a
girl in the US in order of buffalo wings
a legendary burger and a hot fudge
brownie would cost around
$52.95 why in God's green earth is this
burger
$20 it looks good just not $20 good Hard
Rock Cafe is a theme restaurant and I
feel like with a theme restaurant also
comes pretty high prices I think that's
because they're kind of tourist trappy
they think people are willing to pay
more because it's an experience and not
just the food in the UK the same meal
would cost you £
4385 which is
$565 all of this food for
£43 is kind of a lot of food and as
we've discussed a lot of calories but
also I don't think I'm getting that much
value for my money I feel like even in
London I can find better value elsewhere
and I do think it's kind of being
marketed as kind of like a tourist trap
or maybe kind of a special occasion
treat
meal did you know that the first Hard
Rock Cafe was actually opened in London
it was the Hy Park branch and it opened
in 1971 it's pretty rare to come across
a Hard Rock Cafe if you don't live in
like a major city or tourist destination
I think because of that reason they're
not super popular here even though they
are popular in the sense that we know
what it is there are only 34 locations
in the entire us and six of those are in
Florida 18% of the Hard Rock Cafes in
America are in Florida but this is an
international chain so you can find Hard
Rock Cafes in over 50 countries
including Armenia Nepal Nigeria and
Poland Hard Rock Cafe does have a very
dedicated fan base there's a community
of collectors who will buy and swap
commemorative merch from the different
locations including things like the pins
and of course the iconic t-shirt shirts
and jumpers some super fans even
celebrate Hard Rock Milestones like
visiting your 25th location I think I've
got maybe 204 to go same all we have to
do is go to Florida and we can cross six
more off our list they sell normal
American Fair which I can find anywhere
like at a Chili's or an Applebees chains
that are much more available the thing
that makes Hard Rock Cafe special though
isn't the food it's the memorabilia the
first piece of memorabilia donated to
Hard Rock Cafe was Eric Clapton's lead
to Fender in 197 9 since then they have
amassed quite the collection with
86,000 pieces worldwide supposedly it is
the largest private collection of Music
memorabilia in the entire world these
days the memorabilia is still either
donated to them or sometimes purchased
through auctions there are some pretty
cool pieces out there including Elvis
Presley's 24 karat gold leaf piano
handwritten lyrics for John Lennon's
imagine and of course One Directions
iconic phone box which they used in
their album cover
shoes I am so jealous that Harry got to
take a picture with the One Direction
phone booth I don't care if something
good happened to you it should have
happened to me instead I did managed to
get a picture with one of Beyonce's
outfits from her green light music video
it's not as iconic as the One Direction
phone booth but it's something we have a
quote here from one of the Hard Rock
Cafe Founders which we think is quite
interesting it says the Hard Rock Cafe
mayfair's Grace was becoming London's
first classless restaurant at a time
when a baker and a banker could not
commune live shop or Dine together I
think they might be reaching a little
bit here I do think that London in the
70s was kind of in its Punk era I think
social barriers were already being torn
down we'd already had the kind of hippie
movement in the 60s I don't think Hard
Rock Cafe can really claim that they
were the only ones to break down social
barriers and there is nothing more Punk
than the Hard Rock
Cafe love to see a bankery in Hard Rock
Cafe you know what you do when you clock
off you clock off your shift at JP
Morgan and you go straight for a tower
of onion
rings